nous accueillons thierry fontaine qui
est aussi patron de discothèque
président de l'umih dans le département
du rhône bonsoir thierry fontaine ce
sujet qu'on vient de voir a été tourné
il ya environ trois semaines le 31
décembre aujourd'hui où en est on à ce
que vous avez été entendus
alors entendu en sept jours derniers
moments
sur les aides on avance elles sont
clairement pas suffisante pour pour un
mois de décembre supprimés quand on
supprime le mois qui représente 25% du
chiffre annuel c'est difficile juste
opéré coûts fixes mais ça évolue en
avançant de discussion avec bercy sur le
sujet donc c'est plutôt
dur ce qui est perdu toute façon est
perdu on récupérera jamais il faut pas
se leurrer nous entreprises elles sont
durement impactée sur les ouvertures on
voit tout ce qui se passe ce que ce que
mathieu dans le reportage avait souligné
toutes les fêtes privées toutes les
choses comme ça elles ont lieu de
partout ses fins dans les hôtels j'ai vu
dans des épiceries c'est l'éléphant
c'est clairement non marc continue à
faire la fête avec nous sans nous et ça
c'est difficile
pour les chefs d'entreprise que nous
sommes de comprendre ces décisions ont
cette tendance que demain au conseil de
défense sanitaire le gouvernement ne
recolle quinze jours trois semaines de
fermeture en plus avec bien sûr
l'interdiction de consommation debout et
de danse dans les bars on sait que cette
interdiction n'est pas respectée on le
voit tous les week-ends
l'état ne fait rien
peut-être qu'ils veulent la paix sociale
c'est peut-être ça
aujourd'hui nous on est durement
impactée on souffre si on ne garantit
une ouverture dans quinze jours trois
semaines mais une vraie ouverture par
tiens vous ouvrez parce que l'été arrive
et vous fermerez l'été prochain la fin
de l'hiver prochain
on peut l'entendre
il faut que tout le monde soit logé à la
même enseigne il faut que tout le monde
soit traité de la même manière on n'est
pas des sous chefs d'entreprise on est
chef d'entreprise comme les autres on
est je pense très très important pour la
jeunesse elles ont besoin de ça ils font
la fête dans des milieux qui sont
encadrés sécurisé je rappelle quand même
qu'il ya une étude l'étude itoc qui a
été réalisée fin octobre qui soulignent
le fait a été réalisé dans les
conditions réelles un pas comme
certaines études qui demande aux gens où
ils pensent avoir été contaminées pour
moi ça c'est pas une étude je veux dire
le virus c'est pas une morsure de
serpent c'est quelque chose on se rend
compte qu'on a été contaminé 3 4 jours
après en quatre jours on a fait
tellement de choses c'est quand même
difficile de savoir en revanche l'étude
itoc elle l a pris deux groupes un
groupe témoin qui est resté
à la maison bien sagement et un groupe
qui est allé faire la fête dans une
discothèque parisienne
sans masque sans distanciation sociale
et on se rend compte que le résultat de
cette étude montrent qui a pas de
surcontamination entre les gens qui ont
participé à la soirée s'en distancier
sens social et sans masque et les gens
qui sont restés chez eux sont les plus
loin dans cette étude ils ont aussi
comparé par rapport à la population
parisienne au moment de l'étude et là
non plus il n'ya pas de surcontamination
donc que le gouvernement prenne des
décisions soit mais depuis le début on
le clame des études et des données
scientifiques et quand elles sortent
pardonnez moi c'est vrai qu'on a entendu
ce message et on voulait savoir en tout
cas où on est et l'est discothèque on a
eu notre réponse merci beaucoup monsieur
fontaine thierry et à très bientôt pour
un autre témoignage elle